[Music]
we're gonna see housewives from the past
this is gonna be a big week it's gonna
be great
only et was on set with Andy Cohen for
an exclusive tour where the watch what
happens live host shared his initial
reaction after Kenya Moore announced
she's pregnant with her first child I'm
so happy for her but I'm worried because
it's very early we will definitely be
welcoming a boy or girl in late this
year why I don't want to talk about the
details because I'm just still I'm just
still very nervous about everything and
so I just want to get past a safe place
you know I think you're not supposed to
announce it until three months so I'm
just hoping I you know I know that it's
very early so I'm just wishing her very
good health do you want a boy or a girl
I want a healthy baby do you think that
she felt a pressure too because the
girls are so hard on her I think she's
just been wanting a kid for a long I
love that and I'm very happy for her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]